en direct estelle farges devant
l'hôpital bichat à paris
estelle bonsoir alors que peut-on
retenir de cette prise de parole du
ministre de la santé
pas de nouveaux tours de vis un mais une
mise en garde c'est le message adressé
par olivier ferrand lors de ce point
presse hebdomadaire une mise en garde
car le pays se trouve dans une phase
d'aggravation dans la circulation à du
virus
ce sont là les mots du ministre de la
santé cinq métropoles inquiète
particulièrement lille lyon grenoble
saint-etienne et toulouse là bas le taux
de saturation des services de
réanimation avoisine les 30% ces villes
pourraient donc être placées en zones
d'alerté maximale la semaine prochaine
si les mesures actuellement à mise en
place ne produisent pas les effets
escomptés même son de cloche pour paris
et sa petite couronne qui pourrait se
voir placé en zone d'alert maximale et
ce dès lundi je vous proposais ce propos
à d'écouté olivier ferrand la situation
de la métropole parisienne maintenant où
là aussi vous voyez qu'il ya une
dégradation qui s'est accélérée sur
paris et la petite couronne depuis hier
en effet dans les dernières 24 heures
paris a franchi les trois seuils qui
peuvent correspondre à la zone dite d'
alerte maximale
ce franchissement des seuils nous
l'observons que depuis quelques heures
nous avons besoin évidemment de le
confirmer dans les tout prochains jours
mais si ça devait se confirmer nous
n'aurions pas d'autre choix que de
placer paris et la petite couronne en
zone d' alerte maximale et ce dès lundi
enfin concernant les villes de marseille
bordeaux ou encore nice de timides
améliorations ont été observées mais ces
résultats doivent être confirmés dans
les prochains jours un signe
d'encouragement pour olivier ferrand à
poursuivre et à tenir à les efforts
sachez enfin à que le gouvernement va
examiner dans les projets dans les
prochains jours des propositions des
représentant es des restaurateurs à ces
derniers à sont mécontents à d'avoir dû
fermer à leurs établissements notamment
à marseille et bien si ces règles sont
validées par le haut conseil
scientifique
elles pourront à permettre à ces
derniers de garder à leur établissement
ouvert
même dans les zones d'alerté maximale
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions estelle farges en direct
devant l'hôpital bichat à paris